Hunter Conner is at all the clinic they could for your work. I have not.
Their diagnosis are told that my breast cancer is metastasized to my bones.
But would it be helpful for my right to be programmed for that just in case?
Yeah, you can. I mean, yes, yes, and no. If you, if you had no clue that it wasn't that it was metastasized
and you had no inkling that it would be, do we really need to add some bone-building frequencies
and such into their role? We're stealing a little bit of time away from the cancer-killing
frequencies. So I don't put bone-building frequencies in everybody's program if there's no known metastasis.
If after I talked to that person on the phone on their case review and there and then, or you
know they send in the cheek swab when we had a communication link that we think the cancer is growing
many times I will test with the cheek swab. I'll put I'll change that person's program. So that's
why some of you may have gotten a splash drive when you get your cheek swab test done because I tweaked
the program. It may times it's because I put some metastatic frequencies in there to help with
bone-building or something like that. But just as a preventative thing, maybe if you feel in your heart
that maybe that's what, you know, how God's kind of lead you, then I would say there's nothing wrong
with doing that. So but if that's not in your mind at all, you're just thinking, well,
you're just asking the question and I'd say maybe, maybe wait on them. Also, I wanted to take
astro-clear, aroma-clear, and so porozyme instead of letrasol, which is, again, the aromatase
inhibitor drug, which letrasol has caused my bones to ache and my eyes to become so dry that it's
putting eye drops through my eyes all day long. Yeah, there's a lot of side effects to the aromatase
inhibitors. My question is, how much of each should I take? Okay, so I'm just looking at this question now.
So really, I'll have to email you again. I should have made a recommendation so you shouldn't look at
your email, back at your emails. If I made those recommendations, take those things, I made recommendations
for the numbers to take. But I'll look back and I'll try to remember to email you again that if I did
to do that. I also mentioned before that I take the ingredients out of the capsules so that you're
not getting a cellulose in the cell caps. Yeah, that's good. Also, where is the best placement for my
right bulb during the night? Well, if you have breast cancer, it's right up by your chest, by your
abdomen. That's the best placement, really, for almost every cancer. So you're snuggling with that
bulb. How far away from my body and how dear to the breast? Again, the closer it can be to you,
the better. Now, certainly, some people are like really bothered with the bulb next to them,
which is bothers that it keeps them awake. Well, that's where buying the amplifier from true
life can be a benefit that you could put the bulb under the bed. So that's another option for people,
for the few people at that bottom.